Let's be honest, your contribution to
the world so far is a browser history
you make sure no one sees. Incognito
tabs, deleted logs, hours gone, nothing
built. Now, contrast that with this. A
masjid is being completed in a village
in Norway where Muslims have nothing. It
will stand for generations. Those who
donate will be remembered by Allah. And
those who don't will quietly return to
the shadows, back to the consumption,
secrecy, and absolute nothing to show
for it. So, [music] do the right thing.
Post the video or click the link below
and donate for your own akhirah.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. How are you guys doing? And
welcome to another reaction video with
one of the most prolific and interesting
people in the world today. It's Zeeshan
Ali from Smile to the Journey. How are
you, my friend? Absolutely. And that was
100% accurate. Absolutely, brother. One
of the most biggest movers and shakers
in the world today, bro. Absolutely,
brother. Absolutely. Well, we've had a
horrific incident, a monstrous incident
in San Diego.
And it's
something which has been brewing cuz
frankly, now I think Muslims have become
the subject, yeah? They have been the
subject of really the discrimination
from the state level, discrimination
from the populace, discrimination from
institutions, on the media. It's our
time now. It's our time to be
discriminated against. It's our time to
be scapegoated, frankly. I mean, when
you look at what the scholars they say,
there was a time that the Bavarian
Illuminati they were scapegoated, the
Catholics they were scapegoated, the
Jews they were scapegoated, the blacks
they were scapegoated. Now it's just the
time and the turn of the Muslims.
>> Tell me, tell me, and tell the viewers
what happened with this. So, there's a
mosque in San Diego, America, in which
two, well, we know they're 17 and
18-year-olds that went there with the
intention because the mosque is joined
with an Islamic school. So, their aim
was to live stream and shoot children.
Um, to shoot children and people people
in the mosque.
So, what happened was there was a
security guard there and there was
a huge heroic security guard and there
was another individual and both of these
individuals lured the two shooters away,
the two terrorists away and then they
sacrificed their lives and when the two
shooters came back, the school was on
lockdown. There was not a single He had
like a message that he literally put the
day before saying that, you know, he
wants to meet Allah that the best thing
I just want to meet Allah.
It was a couple It was a couple of weeks
before. It was on May the 5th and
absolutely right. He was kind of saying
that he doesn't care about the money, he
doesn't care about beauty, he doesn't
care about the worldly
He cares about is returning to Allah in
a pure clean state and be welcomed by
the angels when a person has a good He
says Khatimah.
You know, I can't remember the exact
wording, but the best ending.
So, him and another brother, they lured
the shooter away, then not a single
child was killed. And alhamdulillah
because the security guard was the one
that people found out about straight
away within 24 hours, the ummah did
something fantastic. They raised a
million dollars for the family of the
security guard and mashallah came
together and you know, really
took on this responsibility that just as
he was protecting the ummah and the
children, mashallah the ummah took it
upon its shoulders to make sure that
they looked after his children and his
family.
Well, that's the thing. I mean, we have
to understand now as Muslim people
that frankly, it's it's our turn. We
have to prepare ourselves mentally and
psychologically for this we are
discriminated against now. And the
Zionist lobby is behind much of this, if
not all of this.
And what they're trying to do is make
life hard for the Muslim people. What I
don't understand Zeeshan is this. You
have the far-right that were protesting
in the UK, all right? You have people in
America who essentially were celebrating
the death of these people in the masjid.
An individual whose name is Laura
Loomer, who might not have been
celebrating in the traditional sense,
but she came out essentially
first of all saying that she had a great
day today, so trying to indicate
something with that. And then talking
about all the the shooters and putting
it in She called it a hoax. She called
it a hoax. Yeah? And when Alex Jones
called Sandy Hook a hoax, his career was
literally brought to his
>> the vile atrocity of an individual.
>> other week the guy had to
>> the vile atrocity of an
>> go to court, and he had to apologize so
many times. This woman
>> a monumental woman. This woman calls it
a hoax, and you know what? Nothing's
going to happen. Yeah? And she is
dehumanizing the people there. She's
saying, "I don't care about this. I care
more about the elections. Forget about
this. These people got it coming and
this and that." You might be wondering
>> that some of them were like
what what were they? Terrorists or
something else? Yeah, calling them
terrorists. Do you I'm not disputing the
vile atrocity of an individual. It's too
much, man. It's too much what you're
doing. And frankly, even Fox News, yeah?
Whenever let's just say a something
happens in a synagogue,
you bring on a rabbi. Something happens
in a church, you bring Yeah, you you
bring a vicar or something. When the
mosque got shot up, they brought on a
rabbi. But was the rabbi bringing
everybody together? No. The rabbi was
saying, "You know what?
I would bet my bottom dollar that, you
know, they firstly they were kids and
they had mental health issues. How is he
calling an 18-year-old a kid? And
secondly, why the hell do we care what a
rabbi thinks when the bodies of our
brothers haven't even become cold yet?
Yeah, it it doesn't make sense.
>> me let me tell you this. And you know
what? You We're talking about Laura
Loomer, yeah? They might be thinking,
you know, what is she and this and that.
Laura Loomer has she is a close
confidant of Donald Trump. In an
interview when she was in India, she was
asked, "How often do you speak to Donald
Trump?" She said, "Oh, before I I came,
I spoke to him two, three times. In a
week, I'll speak to him a couple of
times. I'll go to the White House. I'm
invited there." She is a close confidant
to President Trump, to Marco Rubio. The
question is why have they not spoken
out? Why have they not distanced
themselves from her? Why has Elon not
banned her? Just like her, we saw with
Stricklin and we saw with Hamza Chimaev
the sort of things that Stricklin was
able to say,
allowed to say in the UFC, some of the
stuff that in the Tommy Robinson march
that they were able to say about
Muslims. There's a test. Do this test.
Replace the word Muslim with Jew and if
it's unacceptable, then the question
needs to be asked, "Why is it acceptable
for Muslims?" This is what I want to
know. This is the the true test, right?
And we're having a discussion about this
before the this video is being shot
here. But,
the question is why do these people not
just come out
and agree with fascism?
Because the fact is this, if you look at
the history of fascism and you look at
the definition, an academic definition
of fascism,
there's a significant overlap,
a more than significant overlap, with
fascistic traditional fascistic beliefs,
the like of which were espoused by the
likes of Mussolini and Adolf Hitler,
okay? And what these guys actually want.
What I'm talking about is specifically
the ultra-nationalist element, and we
are speaking specifically
about the fact that they want a specific
minority to be dealt with in a certain
way, which in this case is the Muslim
minority. They want force to be applied
or they
uh they rejoice at force being applied
even illegally and in a vigilante style
to these individuals. So, why do large
swaths of the far right, especially
those who are ethno-nationalist and
others
who want the removal of what they see
now as the Muslim problem, just like
before they saw a Jewish problem, now
the so-called Jewish problem, now they
are so-called Muslim problem.
So, you want to see the removal of these
people, you want to see the suppression
of these people, you want discriminatory
laws against these people. Why are you
holding onto the fact that you are
Democrats? Why are you a holding onto
the fact that you believe in free speech
for all, that you believe in
constitutional rights for all? Why are
you pretending to be a
constitutionalist? Why are you
pretending to believe in first and
second and third amendment rights? Why
are you pretending all those things? Why
are you a coward, an academic and
intellectual coward, and come out and
just say, "You know what? We might
disagree with some of his actions, but
we agree with some of the most of the
ideology of someone like an Adolf
Hitler. We agree with a lot of the idea
We might agree with the actions of
Mussolini, but to frankly or mostly in
the in in England who who had the the
fascist party. We but we agree with most
of the There was a guy called Carl
Schmitt. Carl Schmitt, I had to study
him when I was in university,
and he wrote a book and he he If you
read a book from Carl Schmitt, okay, who
also was
there in
the time of Nazi Germany, and he was
actually a Nazi himself, he was part of
the Nazi party. But Carl Schmitt, who
said that you have to differentiate
between your friend and your foe. And he
If you look at the the rhetoric that
you're seeing on Twitter, when the
far-right circles, in the marches, in
America, in the UK, in the US,
everywhere now, within the elites, in
these institutions,
within the laity,
with these far-right individuals, you'll
see that there's very limited, frankly,
between what fascists, academically,
traditionally, politically, historically
espoused and what these individuals are
espousing. So, I just wonder why these
cowards don't come out and say, "Look,
you know what? Okay, fine. We're not
going to just call ourselves
nationalists. We we agree with this term
fascist."
>> I'll tell you. I'll tell you why they
don't do it. They don't like They don't
want the historical conversation. No,
I'll I'll tell you because there's two
types of nationalists, right? You've got
civic nationalists and you've got the
uh
ethno-nationalists. The
ethno-nationalists are clear. They say
whites only. Yeah. And the Even Even
they don't even call themselves
fascists.
>> And and the civic nationalists, they
say, "You know what? If you are
politically aligned, if you integrate,
if you follow the law, this, that, you
know, you you don't have to be English
or you don't have to be, you know,
within the generation, blah, blah, blah,
to be part of this country." They have a
different criteria. Now, the thing is
that you've got certain Zionist groups,
like Tommy Robinson himself admitted
that Robert Spencer has And this is
after quite a while of him getting
badgered and he finally admitted that he
got $100,000
uh
for for this march. And before, he's
admitted There's a clip when in his
American tour where he talks about Ezra
Levant, again, a Jewish Zionist
individual saying that he trained me, he
helped me, he assisted me, he paid me.
So, the thing with these Zionists is
that if they support the
ethno-nationalists, what's going to
happen is they're going to get kicked
out as well. Because even in Tommy
Robinson's march, there were certain
ethno-nationalists that were there. And
what were they saying? "Kick the
Zionists out as well. We know exactly
what you guys are doing and they're
pissed with the civic nationalist that
they are inconsistent with this sort of
stuff. So, the civic nationalist will
get the payment from the Zionist because
the Zionists uh know that if the
ethno-nationalist get the payment, then
we're out on our ear as well.
>> hit the nail on the head there. And to
be honest, those ethno-nationalists,
even though we don't agree with their
views, and even though they they exhibit
a large degree of fascistic behavior,
which they too cowardly to admit as
well. But even though all that
be the case be that as it may be that as
it may, at least they're not being paid
by these individuals outside and they're
not being controlled, okay? At least
they have some level of um
some some actual allegiance to their own
people, if you want to put it that way.
They're in the whites or whatever they
believe in. But the fact is this, if you
guys believe in this, you are too
cowardly. Now, look, Charlie Kirk got
shot in the neck, okay?
Look how the nation reacted to that.
Even people who disagree with him
vehemently.
>> Some ambulances Some ambulances in this
country were burnt. No one was killed
and they held a Cobra meeting just
because some ambulances in a Jewish area
were burnt.
>> Charlie Kirk was shot in the neck, okay?
He's a public figure. He has
controversial views, but everyone united
condemning the guy.
We're not seeing the same thing with
Muslims, are we?
What does this show?
It shows that you have a large segment
of society within the West where there's
the UK and the US.
>> they think Muslims are the ones killing
people. You don't see Charlie going
around killing people, you job.
Some Muslims are the ones killing
people.
>> a Zionist
genocide on the Palestinians.
Yeah, but he's not bombing people. The
Muslims are bombing people.
>> Charlie Kirk was supporting a genocide,
okay? You can say whatever you like
about
whoever you want, but Charlie Kirk was
supporting a genocide. And if you said a
word about him in the time in that frame
time frame where he died, even now some
right-wing people would just completely
You can't even You can't even repudiate
his views. You can't Right now, if I go
online and start repudiating Charlie
Kirk's views, you're going to see these
nationalists
"How dare you?" And it's Charlie Kirk
and this and that. He got shot in the
neck and it was all "Okay, fine enough.
Okay, no no no." Why you Why is the
outrage so selective? Do you not see
that
you're exposed. You have exposed You
You're a coward. Those Americans, those
Europeans, those English, those Whoever
they may be,
you guys have such a cowardly stance on
this. Just say, "Look, we're racist,
we're fascist, we're discriminatory, we
believe in discrimination, we believe in
two-tier system of law, we believe in
different laws for different people, we
believe these people deserve different
treatment." Just say that. At least now
you can be courageous enough to say
that. Because at this point, that is
what it has become. It has become like
that, okay? We have many discriminatory
laws against Muslims. Look at the
Terrorism Act 2000, which
disproportionately, for example, affects
Muslims.
Schedule 7 as an example, another law
which completely dis- in this country
which completely disproportionately
affects Muslim people.
>> You've got the Patriot Act in America.
>> Act in America, which disproportionately
affects Muslims. And now you have
vigilantism and institutions, and you
have media which disproportionately
minimize Muslim struggle and maximize
Jewish pain. Mhm.
So, you you're trying to make an
inhospitable environment for Muslims to
live. Inhospitable in the West. You're
trying to create it to be difficult for
us. But you know what? That's why we the
Muslims wallahi, that's why we have to
come together. Why we have to unite. Why
we have to found our institutions. Why
we have to like, for example, the
beginning of this, you saw a masjid
project project in What do you call it?
In Norway. This is not a joke. You
should Now it's the 10 days of
Dhul-Hijjah, you should
give money to this. Give money to this.
The Man amalan saleh
Give money. There's no days the prophet
said that are better than these days
in in the deeds. Give money. We have to
start helping each other. Wallahi, these
individuals are not going to help us. We
are bickering, we are divided, we have
jealousy towards each other, we have
resentment towards each other. The The
key to victory, the key to success,
Muslims have to support one another.
They have to unite with one another. The
Muslims in the US and the Muslims in the
UK and the Muslims in France and the
Muslims in Germany and the Muslims all
over the world, the Middle East and
Africa and Asia, every single Muslim
online, financially, economically,
media, social media. Enough of yani
attacking each other, the attacking each
other, the the the charities attacking
people, attacking each other. WHAT THE
HELL? OUR PEOPLE ARE BEING SHOT IN
MASJIDS. It's time to unite. Wallahi,
it's time to unite. Wa tasimu bi
hablillahi jami'an wa la tafarraqu.
Hold on to the Going to have the
priority
>> of Allah.
Hold on to the rope of Allah. Look at
this, our people are going to get shot
and killed. It's going to get worse and
worse if we don't start putting money
into media, putting money into lobbying,
putting money into this, putting money
into schools, education, keep our
identity intact.
Wallahi, we will be they they're going
to humiliate us. It's we're going to
It's going to get worse and worse. They
are going to start admitting their
fascistic. They're going to start making
it explicitly and expressly
discriminatory. If we don't fight
back
If we do not fight back and unite and do
what we need to do as Muslim people,
we're done. We're done in the West,
we're done in the rest of the world. And
trust me, if this is the time.
If you want to continue in your ways,
okay? Ya ayyuhal Muslim, you oh Muslim.
You want to continue in your ways of
division. You want to continue in your
ways of division in your family members,
your brother that you haven't spoke to,
your uncle that you haven't spoke to,
your mother that you haven't Whatever,
your dad and even this guy's in
different tribe and this one's a
Somaliland, this one's Somalia, this
one's this and this and this Pashtun
tribe and this one's other tribe and
this Arab here is Egyptian, this one's
Libyan and this one here is Moroccan and
this one that that one's a Harari, this
one's Algerian and let's fight each
other, let's kill each other, LET'S
LET'S
KILL US.
WHAT?
COME ON, MAN. WAKE UP, MAN. OUR PEOPLE
are being shot in the masjid, akhi.
We're we're we're we're we're we're
we're we're we're sitting ducks for
these individuals, akhi. This is too
much, man. We're in our bubbles.
That's all I have to say.
>> to come out of that bubble, and we need
to look at the bigger picture.
That's all I have to say about this, and
I know that they're going to be donating
for this masjid, and we know that in
these 10 days we're going to be making
dua for our people, our shuhada that
have died in San Diego and everywhere in
the world, whether it's San Diego,
whether it's London, whether it's, you
know, Birmingham, whether it's
Palestine, whether it's Sudan, whether
it's the Uyghurs, whether it's the
Rohingyas. And yes, we haven't forgotten
about the Uyghurs. And yes, we haven't
forgotten about the Rohingyas. And no,
we haven't forgotten about the Sudanese.
We haven't forgotten about any of these
individuals. You probably don't deserve
to watch this video. Your level is
honestly too low to watch this video.
So, feel free to click away from the
video. But for the few who can handle
responsibility, we're building the only
masjid in a village in Norway. First
payment is already done. Final 500,000
remaining. Huge sadaqah jariya waiting.
If you're serious about Islam, you'll
pause the video and you'll click the
link below to donate right now. If not,
[music] enjoy the comment section.